[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: If you are looking
to run queries on data
not already part of public
or shared data sets,
you must first load
your data into BigQuery.
BigQuery accepts data
in several formats.
This video will cover how
to load data from a CSV
file on your local machine into
BigQuery, using the web UI.
This process requires
a Google Cloud Platform
project with billing enabled.
Within your project, you may
take advantage of the Google
Cloud free tier and
bypass cost by staying
within the tier limits for
Cloud Storage and BigQuery.
Loading data into
BigQuery via the web
UI can be done two ways, first
by loading the data directly
from your local machine, or
second by using Google Cloud
Storage as an intermediary.
Direct uploads from your
computer using the BigQuery web
UI are limited to 10 megabytes.
For this reason,
this video will focus
on loading data into BigQuery
by way of Google Cloud Storage,
which doesn't have this limit.
Get started in the
BigQuery web UI.
Identify the data set
to which you would
like to add the new table.
If using an existing data
set, note the data location.
The data location will be
needed in a future step.
If you need to create a
new data set, do so now.
To create a new data set,
select the project name
in the left-hand nav, and
then click the Create Data Set
button.
Name the data set, choose
the data set location,
and then click Create Data Set.
The new data set will shortly
appear in the left-hand nav.
Next, navigate to cloud
storage, by typing "storage"
into the search
bar in the console.
When you arrive, click
the Create Bucket button.
Name your bucket, then
choose the location.
You must choose a location
for your cloud storage bucket
in the same region as the
location of the BigQuery data
set.
The bucket can be either
a multi-regional bucket,
or a regional bucket in the
same region as the data set.
One exception, you can load
data in a US-based data
set from any region.
Since you are creating this
bucket for the sole reason
to transfer the
data into BigQuery,
save on egress
charges by choosing
the exact same location
as your destination
data set in BigQuery.
In this demo, that
is Multi-region US.
Choose the Standard Storage
Class, then click Create.
Now, you may click the
Upload Files button
to select the file
you want to upload,
or simply drag the
file from your desktop
onto the Google Cloud
Storage browser.
Once the upload
finishes, navigate back
to the BigQuery web UI.
Select your data set,
and click Create Table.
Choose Google Cloud
Storage as your source.
Click browse, double-click
on the storage bucket,
and select your data object.
The file format should
update automatically.
Provide a table name.
You can either provide
the schema details,
or click the box to
Auto Detect the Schema.
At this time, you may choose
to partition and cluster
your data.
A video outlining
the hows and whys
of partitioning and
clustering is linked
in the video description below.
If your CSV file
has a header row,
display the Advanced Options and
add the number of head arrows
in the Header Rows
to Skip field.
There are also several other
options you can choose,
including Alternative Field
Delimiters Based on your File.
Now click Create Table.
A load job will be created.
When the job finishes, you can
view the table schema, details,
and a preview of the data.
Now your table is
ready to be queried.
Click Query Table, and a
preloaded query statement
will appear in the
Query Editor, which
you can begin editing directly.
Before diving into
the data, consider
if you would like to delete
the file you originally loaded
into Google Cloud Storage.
Depending on your
situation, it can also
be useful to keep
it as a backup.
Both Cloud Storage and BigQuery
storage have separate pricing,
so be sure to review the pricing
documentation linked below.
Thanks for watching,
and happy analyzing.
[MUSIC PLAYING]